so there's been drilling activity around
Greenland for 39 years i guess it was
suspended for 10 years i'm wondering why
it is generating so much controversy and
excitement now you found my offer for
Leah at the f1 and Lucas gave us a mile
for the hell did boring icon in cydia
it's what the only because Michigan
Scott somehow a little careful at the
facility cow participate stint artists
on some some hockey effective at we did
the debate campaign it was pouring
regular sometimes are still not clean up
there for ya and the reason is probably
that we had the accident in in the Gulf
of Mexico and and there's been a lot of
focus on safety standards since the
accident in the Gulf of Mexico and that
has definitely also meant that there was
a lot of interest internationally around
Greenland different to protect the ocean
we are Katia via Evo's Chilean sea
fishing saturday we had to boy some
cheesy fatigue at the mystery need a
viscosity will be operating income what
is technically we made their settings
point something we have the Phenom at
bonita mas gente de Portugal was human
we believe it they can escape this
medicinal system so this behind you know
my heart to stand up for exhibit that
will go a kia a visually whiskey we've
also more and things we have done is a
number of things in the regulatory
system yeah just to mention some of
these things we have a requirement that
you use to grill Rick's cutting rates so
that you have the capability of drilling
a relief well immediately if you need to
we also have set up standards that
regulate the world operations and we
have adapted the norwegian standards so
called know sock standards that are much
stricter than what you see in for
instance the Gulf of Mexico they're
probably the strictest in the world
right now in terms of ice management we
have adapted the systems that are used
on the east coast of Canada on the Grand
Banks and they have worked very well so
all in all and also in other fields we
have adapted very high regulatory
measures in order to avoid accidents
wetting the shop and lateral taking this
before you dears affiliate therefore it
is it etiquette in 23 of a stoke Sonny's
the hoodie our bass player or the
extrinsic evening how he some points
count really thirsty for the fulness
default also operate me at a at vista
disk come earlier insect aliens are
operated phones so he said the eagle
Antolin for Rollins to use it in 20 ish
we don't have any balloons case on that
lady in question because what we
estimate therefore I will be loyal to
the front of some Timothy a vehicle for
with the AMIA a structure at some point
here is a sum score previously we are
going well the aim and the division is
that this should help create a more
sustainable economy and a more
sustainable industry in Greenland the
aim is to make sure that the Greenlandic
workforce and that between the ending
enterprises can participate in this
development so that we have a
development that includes all of
Greenland we have also in order to take
care of the possible large revenue from
taxes and Royals and so on by law
establish a program front in line with
the norwegian petroleum fund and that is
of course in order to avoid
hyperinflation the so called Dutch
disease but also in order to save up
money for future generations so those
are some of the visions for the future
how important is it for the health of
the Inuit here the Greenlandic in which
social health that they cut off some of
their depend
from Denmark is that a factor at all
beating the churning harder for
dissociated you were gone and offered
corners confining hakuna figures of a
block to school for Denmark he or did it
might come to switch it in the
compliment before at Libya Libya Sylvia
or Mia a nationally and sleep for four
blocks expose my tea party at the whole
entire continent or they started meaning
there distrusted the aetna meaning at
the every horse movies where they sell
phone also rent Oklahoma City sadly we
are if it's self esteem society akoukou
reveal with people's lives that down
well it's an issue that is broadly
debated in Greenland one of the key
issues that I talked about is that it
could key give us a higher self esteem a
more natural pride of being citizens in
our own country and and most people
probably feels that it's a good idea to
get a more self-reliant economy to get
more independence from from Danish
economy that is the majority of the
other of the of the people who has that
view
well what is that reveal a boss who gave
a scene in which in Canada I'm kind
before hall again we got the 50th the
river I'll play with the free estimate
the valves top 20 giving the cool
cabiria at the farm or at their store
for our tanks poses a proper was I witco
so this I we could couldn't we have
fiscally follow Fox's of the support
something to strip me began October
audio or meaning to say to be easily
hidden character for okay that we are
freest like the estimates getting to
stay at the escapee formal so this is
that was a funky will fear kk cabiria
FSK d.c.barry snelfus kv industry well
the message also true to our neighbors
in Canada is that we do this in order to
get a more diversified society and motor
versified economy in Greenland we need
to be able to control the way the
surrounding world is changing and also
the way it affects us here in Greenland
and in order to do that we need to have
more options than just relying on
fisheries because that's a very
one-sided way of maintaining your
economy so we also need other
large-scale industrial projects within
mineral oil and gas activities because
our future and our welfare depend on
developing new business sectors so
that's the message we we convey to
everyone
generally speaking in karnataka Aggie
and the ability vertical the Viacom be a
mere video chat the accp Hoskins
position in a party at the refund and
audit intimately related at least
clarity of a lumia 620 fault was toward
putting more at the b-boy okay the
police's structure the most for me have
fallen by something new ha with a
economy that boy it kept the key
publicist wait before at the biscuit boo
starting in something scopus I cook gets
word networking / hot gym that day I
just created with a few paths with my co
was much more our lives former we was
born for fiscal farmers on phone or in
with control it they're giving you the
taper spirit lee de my overly fight me
again but we don't know whether we
actually more willing to take risks as
such but we are we're come to a point in
the Greenlandic development where we are
capable of taking independent steps
ourselves both in in the political
development here we are the level where
it's natural for us to take steps ahead
and we also have a development of the
economy and social structures that makes
it possible for us to do that in a
controlled way of course it is at the
same time important that we do it in a
way where we could take our original
values or original inner it culture we
are very much related to to hunting and
fishing so we have to do it in a way
where we still respect the original
values again is very bad first in the
cast on the dates on invisible and
distance for Newfoundland up in Bahia we
get to show her the cadets our vitamin
you found them okay left so your son
went to win spaces or chicken tubes for
all its immensity and your front leg
with tio your fam windows or editing of
stars fearsome and hockey recording the
fourth kinda might intercept for us who
are cuckoo for the best movie if it
miracle for the heads up on or something
me the applicator serious into Street
the wolf
Newton's or it is pd might in society
behavior Chesser Marcus cohort leaving
your front ankle well in terms of
knowledge and the degree of development
within the oil and gas sector
newfoundland is of course 10 years or
more advanced than we are therefore it's
natural that the be looking around that
in order to see how we can learn from
from the development they're not least
and how you have been able to include
the following distri the suppliers the
national industry how have you been able
to make sure that those kind of
companies were put in a situation where
they could be suppliers or even
participating in indy oil industry so so
basically that's how we see the
development audit of the possible
cooperation basically how can we learn
from you and and but i also think that
that probably you are interested in our
development as well because we are a new
market possibly for things i add at kiva
company founder now among the fountain
haasika from TSM some summit summit
either service base isn't quite as food
industry
the ecotec the train kyoukai fiscal you
might the teleporting I in antistia this
fiscal import a headache the Sun in the
Sun comes Molly divorce a possible for
speedy missile against buying a wood so
I can leave nearly at the Heritage some
of us forward merely neatly one can't
would be that the thank you purposely
tikz of yours well as it's possible very
fact that the founder and green and are
geographically close to each other makes
it very thinkable that that we will work
together if we have high production here
in Greenland so we'll have to wait and
see but it's a possibility because the
same region again visit but n1 degrade
over can the first for what I mean when
I'm very soon will mother champion you
up to yeah it was a deal mr. Mason's
what they're for Cohen my nature is can
have it if they said scared really
elddim I would be faulty someone hunter
who dis escape review my focus you it
has more at the kia pro as a hobby it
won't assist in here again the car at
every hace que fue mejor today up I'd
nice escape of or what mp4 had thought
that they will occur after a bookkeeper
una students is stealing a hot cocoa a
kiss of what it a pity that the audience
erica is often be really
kokia total control so hopefully they
adhered with Egypt for her Lars at its
amaavas por hora de alcalá de we are
cuckoo there is an in-between by the
Holy Trinity philippi default is among a
religious diversity of a 34 how can you
let you have to dig my proposal
impossible well first of all can is a
little bit different than many other
companies in that they they focus a lot
when they when they work in different
areas they are more progressive in in
the way that they typically point out an
area where they focus on and earlier it
was in India where they have it had a
lot of success in finding and developing
an oil fields and now they have through
a number of years worked on putting
green and into a position where that is
the focal point of their international
strategy right now also the minster
points to that is very important that
from an authority point of view we have
what you call a one door system or a
one-stop-shop Authority which means that
the industry only have to approach one
Authority which is the Bureau of
minerals and petroleum and at the Bureau
of milk petroleum we handle all
relations between the government and the
oil industry so when they apply for a
permit to an oil well they do not have
to go around and talk to five or six
different ministries they go to one
Bureau that takes care of all the
authority matters and then have the
contact to other industries if they need
to but the industry doesn't have to go a
lot to a lot of ministries and that
makes the makes the whole public
administration very effective and also
means that we can act in a filthy faster
and
places on a longer basis that's my own
comment why I can will basically bag in
around two thousand and one and two
thousand two we decided on a new
strategy for tracking oil activities to
Greenland the government actually
decided to approve a strategy
hydrocarbon strategy while we were going
to have licensing rounds often on the
west coast of Greenland we were going to
make sure that a lot of seismic data
were acquired we invited the
international seismic industry to
acquire data in Greenland because that
is probably the thing you need to do you
need to have data that the industry can
do get in order for them to come and
evaluate the hydrocarbon potential in
depth as a result of that we have had a
number of licensing rounds in the last
eight nine years we've had it in two
thousand two four six seven and 2010
we're going to have licensing round
again in 2012 and 13 on the east coast
of Greenland so we have through the last
eight nine years attracted a lot of oil
companies not the only can other
companies that have licenses in
Greenland is companies like our
companies like Exxon Chevron also the
Danes company don't ask you from Canada
for instance and cannot apply since this
year and a lot of major companies are
right now negotiating for new license
blocks on on west coast of green and
apparently so it's not only can can is
just one of many companies but they are
ex more rapidly when they go from the
face where they acquire geophysical data
line seismic data and to the phase where
they drill
scalpel fo de la manana hasta to share
44 children kousaka in which normally
power for twisting before the ICC have
taken alpha some enoki do by someone
obviously heart is could hear the vows
of love east of Austin see Jillian's are
only the family we pop against mine was
Bernie novices clear to the gear no let
up till at the weekend with some of our
CCO made it be a mere software the
film's position for a cuckoo for a week
since McGraw rascally open seasonally or
anta civilians position kk the opposite
of our common service London EOC city
include people here lent also at the
Oscar Campbell Willie it was never get
me or international service at the
position the capital of new autumn ask
icc had the General Assembly meeting
here in nuke in the summer of 2010 and
that means saying they also discussed
the drilling activities hearing offshore
green line in 2010 / carb adelson
Minister on Ireland gas actually
presented to the ICC assembly our plans
here in Greenland foil activities and
one of the things that were put before
the ICC is that we would like to
cooperate even closer with the ICC and
other NGO organizations in order to make
sure that we have an effective and
comprehensive hearing process in order
to make sure that all parts of the
population are included in the first in
the process took west to the best
possible effect you might say how do i
decided to escape sealed in with boba
and 11 and Jerry gallo digiti r the
leading 40 at the weirdest from who you
know was it was that how more mean heavy
at the restaurant I begin with let me ha
the manual a fine for the you said some
Julia industry identify a hard day okay
the IC siska see also TV here i hocked a
paz que te voya positive negative India
Nepal for locals upon me ova as a foodie
will fatigue
the continent they have to the fishbowl
active allari the low cumin the chip
Syria the friendship up in bed the heat
on believe me it was Molly or a chemist
from here but then we via their origins
or aunt is a scallion check the cat
therefore it is supposedly industry up
our stove or its control before or
afterwards if the common mean at the
rate of a unique virtue godly BBL some
mainly we fight the philosophy at the at
the right policies get there are
partisan remotely associated or policy
at the cell phone is that we had it 20
40 times Susie arasima or some his uncle
sam up soon is that we look for it they
repair it will attend a party or that a
crack whateva was a said also optical
industry it was Kelly we added a big
black services of nvidia or he communist
trailer is crystal traded immediately I
think that this course operative or
severely disciplined
well the minister doesn't have a direct
message to other you know H populations
elsewhere in the world he also wants to
reply to that we haven't yet found on
commercial quantities so there's still a
bit a bit ahead of us also we know that
Alaska and Canada there has many years
of experience on coexisting boo the oil
industry ICC appointed both to negative
and positive effects for the local
population as a result of that
development in Alaska and Canada and
based on those experiences from Canada
and Alaska we have made sure that we
that the legislation in Greenland have
included aspects that make sure that a
social sustainability is an integral
part of the requirements when you do oil
activities also we have made sure that
the legislation focuses on Environmental
Protection and we also make sure that a
reasonable proportion of the income will
go to Greenland of course money alone
does not make a good life you cannot be
sure that you have it just because you
have good income but they are necessary
if you want to make sure that you can
develop the level of education if you
want to make sure that you have a good
social system and if you want to make
sure that you can provide good health
services to the population it's so
therefore this development is is
necessary if you want to make sure that
you have a well-educated population that
can take care of themselves and also if
you want to have a population that can
actually be the
the main resource when you build up a
new business sector in green that could
make the economy of green and
self-reliant
and minister pronounce your name so i
make sure i pronounce it right well we
caught pattinson my name is john scott
nelson